[音楽]
[拍手]
こちらは1938年に
現在の
広島平和記念公園で撮影された写真です
後ろに写っている建物は
現在の
原爆ドーム
当時は
広島県産業奨励館と呼ばれていた建物です
これをカラー化してみます
まるで今
二人の兄弟が私たちに話しかけてくるよう
に見えてきませんか
私は高校時代から
原爆投下前の日常を捉えた
白黒写真を
AI技術や
当時の資料をもとにカラー化して
戦争体験者と
対話することで
記憶の色を蘇らせて
戦争体験者の思い
標高未来へ継承する
教育の回答という取り組みを進めています
私は広島出身で
初めて原爆について学んだのは
幼稚園の時です
右に写っているのが私です
被爆による惨状を受け止めきれず
資料館を出る頃には
泣いていた記憶があります
また小学校でも毎年平和学習をするうちに
悲惨な光景から学ぶ平和学習について
だんだんと苦手意識を持つようになりまし
たそれが変わったのは小学5年生の時に
もらった1枚のパンフレットがきっかけ
です
これは開いていくと
現在の
広島平和記念公園とかつての中島地区が
見比べられるようになっていて
戦前の日常とらえた白黒写真が掲載されて
いました
今と変わらない日常があったことそれが
たった一発の原爆で一瞬にして
失われてしまったことを
初めて自分事として想像することができ
ました
世界で唯一の被爆国日本そして広島に
生まれたものとして
戦争体験者の思い
記憶を受け継いでいきたいでも当時の私に
はどうすることもできませんでした
本や新聞から学ぶことしかできませんでし
た
そんな中高校1年生の夏
平和公園で偶然であったのが
甘い特捜さんです
現在の広島平和記念公演は
原爆投下前
4400人が暮らす
広島1の繁華街中島地区と呼ばれていまし
た
赤い矢印の先にあったのが
浜井さんの成果で
浜入り初感です
この世界の片隅にの中には
ご家族が登場しています
珠江さんと母伊藤さんがハマり初冠の前で
一緒に映った写真
父じろうさんが
散髪をする写真
これらは
浜井さんが疎開先に持っていたために残っ
た大切なアルバムの中に
収められていました
貴重な白黒写真
約250枚
浜井さんご自身は
疎開していたために助かりましたがたった
一発の原爆で一瞬にして
[音楽]
ご家族全員を
失いました
アニメ映画の中のご家族に会うために何度
も映画館を訪れているというお話を伺って
白黒写真をカラー化して
プレゼントして
ご家族をいつも近くに感じてもらいたい
その思いからカラオケを始めました
近所にあった桜の名所
長寿園でのお花見の写真です
AIでカラー化するとこのようになります
家族がまだ生きているようだ
昨日のことのように思い出すそう浜井さん
は喜んでくださいました
会おうとした杉並木を見て
浜井さんがこの杉並木の杉並をとって杉
鉄砲の玉にして友達という遊んどったんや
と
この近くに弾薬庫があって
幼心に怖かったんよと
白黒写真では思い出せなかった記憶が新た
に蘇りました
また
家族や親戚近所の人と花見をしていたと
いうお話から
花の色
手作業で老舗したものはこちらです
このようにカラー化写真を元に戦争体験者
と対話することで
記憶の色をよみがえらせて
未来へ継承していくこの取り組みを記憶の
回答と
呼び始めました
その後も中島地区出身の方々から
写真を提供していただいて
取り組みを進めています
その中で受け取った思い記憶を私のところ
だけではなくてより多くの人に
共感とともに伝えていきたい
そう考えて
展覧会や
常設展示映像
作品
記憶の回答ARアプリまたこれを使って
歩く平和公園
他にもマスメディアであったり
国際会議の場であったり
様々な
平和教育の教育空間を通して
発信してきました
大学進学後はカラー化写真集や音楽との
コラボレーションにも
挑戦しました
こちらが2020年春までのカラー化写真
をまとめた
写真集です
レビューを700件以上いただく中で
カラー化写真を見るという
語幹に
五感を通して感性に響かせておのずから
伝えたくなるということが大切なんだと
感じていました
そんな中で
毎月
毎月6日に開催している
被爆体験
語り部の会を広島出身のシンガー
ソングライターヒッピーさんがされている
んですがそこに浜井さんと私でゲストとし
て呼んでいただきましたこれがご縁で
カラー化写真と音楽のコラボレーションに
取り組みます
カラーカ写真を見るということに加えて
音楽を聴くという
語幹を通した伝え方で
感性より感染に響いて自分ごととして想像
してもらう空間を作りたいそう考えました
アラブメモリー
記憶の色
カラーか写真集を通して
みんなでイメージを膨らませていってまず
ヒッピーさん
ピアニストで作曲家の裸の子さんと共に
楽曲をそして
映像作家の立ち富さんと
ミュージックビデオを制作していきました
かなこさんが最初に作ってくださってても
音源を聞きながらこれまで受け取った思い
記憶を
言葉にして音に載せて
作詞を始めてしました
ヒッピーさんにも
素敵な歌詞を加えていただいて出来上がっ
たものがこちらです
[音楽]
お別れも言えないママ
突然一人ぼっちになったハエさん
平和公園で偶然であって
対話を重ねてカラー化していくうちに
どんどん
モノクロ世界からカラーに変わっていき
ました
[音楽]
原爆投下後焼け跡に残されたさら時計が
あります
8月6日8時15分でたまったままです
その針がだんだんと
刻み始めました
大好きなご家族にはもう会えないけど
幸せな未来へ
記憶をつないでいこう紡いでいこうそして
中島
地区という平島だけではなくて
宇宙へ
たった一つのかけがえのない
青色の地球へと視点が映っていきます
また
戦争がなくなるだけではなくて
社会にはたくさんの問題がありますそれを
解決していつの日かまた出会った時に
地球とみんなが
笑っていてほしいそういう思いを込めまし
た
ミュージックビデオは
立ちトミさんとヒッピーさんと話し合って
制作をしていきました
戦後70年までお墓を建てられなかった
浜井さん
平和公園を訪れる時には今も
現場今も平和公園の地下にはたくさんの人
が眠っているんだということを想像し
ながら
歩いてほしい
浜井さんの思いを
浜井さんの声で残したいと提案して
いただいて出来上がったミュージック
ビデオの一部をご覧いただきます
[音楽]
青色の地球
宇宙で一つ
影がえのない
[音楽]
命
どこか隠れてるんじゃないかのっていつも
思うよ
来るたびにね
75年待ってね
帰ってこのところ見るとやっぱり
寂しい思いがしよう俺に
今年で終戦から77年を迎えます
私たちが直接商業を抱える最後の世代です
戦争体験していない世代による継承が重要
となる中で
関心や
無意識によって戦争体験の
風化が進んでいますその一方で
長い時を経たからこそ
当事者が少しずつ語ることができるように
なったということもあります私はその中で
中島地区出身の方々に出会ってきました
残念ながらこの中にはすでに亡くなられて
いる方もいらっしゃいます今という時間は
とても貴重な時です
戦争を体験していない世代にできること
それは
被爆者の思い記憶を戦争体験者の思い記憶
を未来へ継承していくことです
どうしても当時の悲惨な光景や
感情というものは当事者にしかわからない
ことがあります
でも
制裁平和についてあまり関心のない人にも
音楽や
想像してもらいながら
教科の輪を広げていくこと
音楽や写真集いろんなものを通して
自分ごととして
考えていくことそれが大切になってきます
また大きな歴史上としての戦争ではなくて
一人一人の
重い記憶に
目を向けていくそこに想像力を働かせて
いくということが
重要になってきます
もう
誰にも同じ思いさせてはならないという
戦争体系者の思い記憶を
交感通して伝えていくことそして一人一人
の思いを伝えていくという面では
厄災に通じることでもあります
実は今日
ヒッピーさんとはらかなこさんにもお越し
いただいています今ここに
集まっている皆さんと一緒に
平和教育の教育空間を作れたらと思ってい
ますカラーオブメモリを歌いますのでぜひ
聴いてください
[拍手]
[音楽]
ひとりぼっちの
柄の世界
あの人またありがとう
自慢のお姉ちゃん
優しい
お母さん
いつも
近くに
感じている
[音楽]
花を
守る
大好きな
家族にはもう
会えないけど
花を
幸せなり
紡いでよかった
[音楽]
ひとりぼっちの
青色の地球
宇宙で一つだけが
えのない
[音楽]
命
大好きな
家族にはもう
会えないけど今お前は
[音楽]
幸せな未来
駅を
つないでいくその
[音楽]
腰に
刻まれてる
ひとつふかつくなお面もり
幸せな記憶
巡り巡ってく
いつの日かまた
あなたとで
その時は
地球と
みんなが笑ってどこ
[音楽]
[拍手]